muss man so laut sein mittlerweile muss
man solche Aktionen auf die Straße
kleben festketten machen um überhaupt
wahrgenommen zu werden
aber ansonsten ist es ja ein unsinniges
ganze aber bitte schön wenn es soweit
macht es heute ich meine das ist ja für
die kennt eben bitte das beste hat
vorhin irgendwo sich festbinden und dann
bleiben dort lassen Antrieb also
irgendwo gelesen der Ötzi war vielleicht
anders vergessen haben
es hört sich irgendwo festgeklebt und
war dann nicht mehr wieder auszufinden
aber ist ja wirklich absurd was sich
abspielt ich meine es lässt sich diese
Wissenschaftler meine was heißt hier
Wissenschaft wie die haben überhaupt
keine Ahnung
jetzt sind wir bei diesen Aktionen und
reden darüber muss man das machen um
aufzufahren alle berichten in
Deutschland noch einmal an wie die
Franzosen mit dem umgehen die gehen ein
bisschen brutaler wenn man ganz einfach
seine Gegenwehr ich meine das ist das
ist sicherlich ein riesen Problem wegen
einer Form zu agieren was kann wenn man
jetzt vor der Situation steht da steht
ein Rettungswagen und dahinter ist ist
ein verunfall da und dazwischen sind
Leute die sich festgeklebt haben sowas
macht ihr jetzt machen was konkret sie
stehen da im Stau stehen erste Reihe
vorhin hat sie sich Herr Dr Zander auf
die Straße gesetzt hat sich schon
festgeklebt sie warten jetzt erstmal
schöne Stunde im Berufsverkehr in Berlin
da bin ich sehr dafür und das sehr
brutal zu regeln die Hände wegzureißen
wenn man zudem
aus oder sagen sie der Polizei runter
wir müssen dorthin ja ist doch das geht
ums Leben
auf ihre Kappe jetzt sagt Ihnen Herr
Thoma ja der sonst weitestgehend einer
Meinung ist mit Ihnen hier in dieser
Runde heute abend sie sind viel zu weit
sie klopfen da große Sprüche in München
selbst im von Bayerns oder von
Deutschland härtesten Innenminister
sagte das ist viel zu weit sie müssen es
sie müsst ihr einfach runter holen davon
der Straße
ja das tun wir ja auch dafür haben wir
extra inzwischen jetzt überall
Lösungsmittel um die Leute die sich
festhalten
und manche lassen sich dann wieder neues
Klebemittel einfallen
aber es ist ganz lächerlich solange man
das selber in dem Stau steht und was da
nämlich passiert sieht anders aus als
das was die Schilder haben das überall
das Lösungsmittel hergeholt wird und so
da guckt man zu wie sich festgeklebt
wird und dann kommen Rettungssanitäter
dazu weil es könnte ja mal ablösen
nichts passieren wäre und es ist doch
eine Verhöhnung des Rechtsstaates da
passiert die Polizisten stehen
stundenlang daneben
nein das ist ja eben nicht der Fall wenn
wir rechtzeitig darauf aufmerksam werden
dann verhindern wir dass jemand sich da
festklebt und wir ständig das gehört
natürlich hier zu den besonderen
Herausforderungen dass die ja irgendwo
hingehen jedenfalls in Bayern haben wir
eine klare Linie wenn ihr irgendwo
verhindern
unsere Demokratie ja das darf ich Ihnen
vielleicht auch mal einmal Ausreden
jawohl
jawohl Innenminister ja und dann wieder
ich ja denn das entscheidende vorhin was
Herr Zander gesagt hat das ist diese
wissenschaftliche Arroganz die bei ihm
durchdringt ich habe großen Respekt vor
Wissenschaftlern aber demokratie heißt
das in unserem Staat jede Frau und jeder
Mann das gleiche Recht hat und jeder hat
bei der Abstimmung eine Stimme was sich
was so wie Herr Zander sich angehört hat
mündet daraus eine Anspruch dass er
einen größeren Anspruch hätte gehört zu
werden mit seinen Argumenten bei der
Wissenschaftler ist ja er kann mit
seinen Argumenten entsprechend
rüberkommen aber am Schluss gibt es eine
Abstimmung egal ob der Bundestag gewählt
wird oder eine Volksabstimmung in bei
einem Bürgerentscheid in München
stattfindet und da hat jede Frau und
jedermann das gleiche Recht er kann
nicht mit einer Arroganz auftreten dass
er das besser weiß als der erfahren oder
der Hausmeister vom Internist und das
müssen sie ja Zander jetzt mal
akzeptieren sie dreht mit einer Arroganz
auf weil sie Wissenschaftler sind hätten
sie einen Anspruche darauf dass alle auf
das zu hören haben was sie meinen und
das ist nicht auf der Kerze und damit
leben sie nämlich genau die Grundsätze
unserer Demokratie aus und das ist nicht
akzeptabel ich bin als Innenminister
dafür verantwortlich dass weiterhin in
diesem Land gilt gleich ist recht für
alle Grundlage unseres corona-pandemie
da wurde sehr gut auf die Wissenschaft
gehört wir tragen Masken wir haben uns
impfen lassen die corona-pandemie ist
eine Folge der Umweltkrise warum wird
nicht jetzt auf die Wissenschaft gehört
und etwas gegen die Umwelt und auch
gegen die Klimakrise getan es geht
glaube ich gerade sehr durcheinander
weil in der in dieser corona-pandemie
wieder zurücknehmen vorher beschlossen
nie geschlossen werden also glaube beim
BVG tragen wir auch die Masken ich
gehöre ja zu den Leuten diese ganzen
Corona Sachen alle befolgt haben und so
weiter ich würde sagen ich bin auch
keine klimaexpertin aber was ich
natürlich 2018 hat doch 19 angefangen
habe zu lesen ist dass es nicht so ist
wie ein Herr Riese und andere gesagt
haben dass alle Wissenschaftler sich
einig sind es gibt eine ganze Menge
Wissenschaftler die nicht der Meinung
sind dass wir in drei Jahren
den Kipppunkt haben es gibt ganz andere
die auch seriös wirken sagen es sind 80
Jahren noch irgendwie Zeit haben
da ich kann mich noch nicht einmischen
weil ich keine wissen das werde ich auch
nicht mehr in meinem Leben aber es geht
ja darum wie kommt man jetzt effizient
dazu dass wir ein Klimaschutz in diesem
Land
und jetzt behaupte ich die ganzen
Aktionen die sie extrem Rebellen gemacht
hat und diese ganzen anderen
Gruppierungen haben bis jetzt 0,0 für
den Klimaschutz erreicht
genau
jetzt passiert genau das nämlich beim
Klima auch der klima-lockdown ja aber
entschuldigung es ist ja nicht
feststehend das ist doch immer wieder
was wie wird argumentiert
Wissenschaftler 1200 wissen das ist doch
gerade kein demokratischer Vorgang waren
1200 und es gibt dann vielleicht 800 die
dagegen sind also dann haben die haben
die Recht es ist nur Demokratie so aber
berichte stimmt nicht das sind weltweite
Wissenschaftler
aber sie hat gerade gesagt Sie haben
gerade Corona als Beispiel angeführt das
war der Testlauf ja wie man wie man
sozusagen testen kann wie man eine
Gesellschaft lahmlegen kann
der Klimakrise das habe ich gesagt der
Groner Krise ist eine Folge der
Umweltkrise weil wir die Natur
eingeschränkt haben
die Menschen leben mehr aber wir
Wünschen zusammen
gar nicht belegen heute abend
ich wünsche mir BürgerInnenversammlung
bürgerräte wo wir als beteiligt
dann bleiben sie wir verlangen das von
der Politik das
bürgerinnenräte eingeführt werden und
wir dann gemeinsam entscheiden von einem
Durchschnitt der Gesellschaft was für
klima-maßnahmen wir wollen wir brauchen
als Bevölkerung weil ich glaube nämlich
dass die Bevölkerung schlauer ist
teilweise als die Politik
es tut mir leid nein nein innerhalb der
Demokratie
müssen wir Bürgerinnen
sie wollen sich von unserem Grundgesetz
verabschieden
ausprobiert in Deutschland ja aber sie
wollen politische Entscheidung Ersetzen
von parlamentsentscheidungen zu
bürgergeräten und das ist ein anderes
System wir leben in der
parlamentarischen Demokratie wir geben
macht auf Zeit wir können die Leute
wieder abwehren wenn Sie falsche
Entscheidungen treffen wir können Sie
unterstützen wenn sie gute Entscheidung
getroffen haben wenn sie Vertrauen
genießen das Zeichen unserer Demokratie
aus das was sie machen wollen die
legitimierte Bürger Rede die quasi per
Zufallsprinzip sie zusammensetzen
Parlamentsentscheidung ersetzen ist
nicht dieselbe Demokratie in der wir
jetzt gerade leben können Sie mir
erklären wo die Politik richtige
Entscheidungen trifft wenn ein Konzern
wie
www.3 Monate drei acht Milliarden Euro
Gewinn gemacht haben können Sie das den
Leuten hier erklären
Milliarden Gewinn gemacht mit einem
netten wir wissen nicht wie wir
problemsmittel einkaufen sollen wir
wissen nicht wie wir unsere Gasrechnung
zahlen sollten darüber zu diskutieren
das wäre mal aber ja
was wir mit den hohen Gasrechnungen
machen in der Tat und aber woran liegen
den Punkt den den Herr Dr Zander
aufmacht ist das Misstrauen in die
Politik das erleben wir ja nicht nur von
den Klima Klebern das erleben wir in
weiten Teilen der Bevölkerung
mittlerweile das heißt das scheint ja
ein Punkt zu sein das Misstrauen in die
Veränderungsbereitschaft in die
problemlose Lösungsfähigkeit von
Politikern das muss man auch sagen ist
seit 50 Jahren gibt es eine
Protestkultur in diesem Land die immer
also wirklich das ist ja schon
langweilig auf der Stelle treten sagt
sie wollen die anderen immer die anderen
aufrütteln es ist permanente
Aushandlungsprozess permanent gute und
Andreas Bade gemacht als sie die
Kaufhäuser angezündet haben ja ist auch
wenn sie das nicht wissen dann ist es
trotzdem so dass ihre Protest ihr
protest movement immer noch in diesem
ausreden lassen bitte
da sie die Kauf jetzt so nicht warum um
ein Zeichen zu setzen um aufzurütteln
damals ging es um Vietnam und es ging
übrigens auch schon damals um
konsumscheiße also es ist gar nicht so
wahnsinnig weit und dieses ich fand es
eigentlich eine Zumutung dass ich
dauernd aufgerüttelt werden soll von
solchen Aktionen und warum eigentlich
nicht innerhalb der Demokratie innerhalb
der Grünen innerhalb der Parteien warum
immer non govern Mantel warum immer
außer parlamentarisch warum nicht
innerhalb der Partei innerhalb der
Demokratie hypothetisch die Frage aber
ihre Mutter deren Gefährten würden sich
heute möglicherweise dieser Bewegung
anschließen oh das kann ich nicht
beurteilen aber die haben sich auf jeden
Fall eben mit diesen Fragen genau
rumgeschlagen also nicht mit dem Klima
aber die haben sich mit dem Fragen der
Proteste des aufmerksam machen dann
haben Sie erkannt dass die Gesellschaft
lässt sich nicht aufwecken und dann
haben sich einige radikalisiert und
gesagt wir müssen es mit roter
nein nein
nein
halbwegs logisch machen reden ähnlich
aber ganz ein anderes Thema sie haben
auch damals gedacht es nützt nichts weil
wir friedlich demonstrieren es nützt
dann im nächsten Gang nicht wenn wir
Sachbeschädigung machen und dann sind
einige das war ja nicht die ganze
Bewegung und das waren ja nur einige
haben dann gesagt wir müssen noch
Radikale werden ich glaube Herr Dr
Zander dass er nicht radikaler wird es
kann aber andere der Bewegung geben die
er gar nicht kennt und es kann Dynamik
sein aber ich will die auch gar nicht an
die Wand malen ich sage nur was ich viel
schlimmer finde ist dass es wir haben so
eine Art Liebe zu diesem Protestierenden
in diesem Land seit 68 Deutschland das
ist in Frankreich genauso das ist
überall so
eigentlich eigentlich alle Menschen
protestieren wir sind wir sind immer auf
der Seite wir auf der Gesellschaft die
Zeitung die Medien die Polizisten immer
auf der Seite sehr protestieren denn und
ich denke oft sie sollte doch vielleicht
mehr auf der Seite sein der die
versuchen in einer Demokratie ihre
Anliegen vorzulegen als immer denen die
es mit Gewalt und sabotageaken
entscheidend
durch mit dem Thema was erreicht und
Deutschland
1,8 Prozent der Welt Klimas ist in
in Russland ganz ganz anders vor der von
der amerikanischen finden Sie wie viel
auf welchem Platz Deutschland stehen
wenn man 1800 kommen auf 1850 bis heute
ganz normal steht Deutschland
die Radikalisierung die ja auch zum Teil
in der Klima Protestbewegung jetzt schon
da ist jetzt nur Datenschutz was
innenminister Herrmann gesagt hat im
vorsorgen der Staat da muss die Regeln
neu justieren wenn wir sehen dass es
sich radik passiert dass sozusagen die
Schwere der Taten größer wird ein
heftiger wird dann gibt es gerade
Initiative die Macht die cdu/csu jetzt
diese Woche im Deutschen Bundestag dass
wir auch darüber reden müssen müssen wir
im Strafgesetzbuch neue Tatbestände
verankern die darauf Rücksicht nehmen
dass möglicherweise die Eingriffe durch
den Protest stärker werden dass die
Schwere der Taten größer wird und
deswegen da auch eine Freiheitsstrafe
eine mindestfreiheitsstrafe
implementiert wird im Strafgesetzbuch
der mit Richter bei Wiederholungstätern
bei intensivstraftätern dann auch eine
mindestfreiheitsstrafe verhängen können
und eben nicht nur vielleicht ein paar
hundert Euro Strafgeld und dann ist
alles wieder alleine
präventiv möglicherweise wirkt weil das
ist ja das was die Autofahrer auf den
Straßen für Tag immer wieder passiert
können Sie garantieren dass das in drei
in sechs Monaten vorbei ist
ich kann das nicht garantieren weil ich
nie garantieren kann was jemand nächste
Woche oder in einem halben Jahr für
Unfug macht aber was ich garantieren
kann ist dass wir konsequent gegen alle
Rechtsprecher vorgehen werden und ich
kann feststellen nach wie vor zu 99%
rollt der Verkehr in Bayern egal ob das
im Züge oder um Autos und wir werden
weiterhin alles dafür tun sollten Unfug
in Grenzen zu halten
also noch etwas
bescheidenes anmerken was bescheiden ist
von ihnen bescheiden ist nämlich dass
die ganze Diskussion hier langsam das
was er macht enorm hochjubelt auch was
die da alles erzählen was sie für für
Maßnahmen ergreifen wollen das ist hier
an dem was auf der Erde geschieht das
was im Mittelmeer geschieht das was in
der Ukraine was in Afrika geschieht ihr
nehmt euch zu wichtig ihr nehmt euch so
wichtig mit diesem kleinen
wir machen ein ganz kurzes Pause wie wir
uns irgendwann hier Wiedersehen
Innenminister danke nach München nächste
Woche wieder hier bei Bild die richtigen
Fragen Montagabend
[Musik]